let's take a look at how set timeout
might be implemented if it was written
natively in JavaScript and we could go
read the file somewhere we'll pretend
for a moment that it's defined in a file
somewhere called timers jeaious what
would you expect to see appearing in
this file I mean first of all there'd be
a function definition where set timeout
is a variable defined and made to point
at some function that function would of
course take two arguments your callback
and the number of milliseconds to wait
before calling that callback what would
happen in the body of the function well
first of all of course somehow the
system delays execution of your callback
by a number of milliseconds note that if
you understand how Java scripts
concurrency model works you know this
couldn't actually be done in native
JavaScript but it's still a useful
example to imagine the next thing that
set timeout would have to do is refer to
your function and it would have to
somehow invoke it here we're finally
able to ask ourselves the question what
values is set timeout likely to pass
along to your callback function since
set timeout has no way of knowing what
values you wanted pass to your function
perhaps it would be forced to simply
invoke it with no parameters at all if
that were the case what would you expect
to be shown in the last position of the
log output